peu
[Musique]
[Rires]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi vrai que je me donne le rôle des
casques et commentaires allonger la
moitié de sa fortune avec les faux et
que le soleil joue le mari jaloux je
vous jure que semaine écoulée suis prêt
à chercher comme elles ont bon vieux
gentilhomme aussi vrai que je me dope le
compte de quoi que mon aïeul était un
bâtard du bon roy henry et qu'il refuse
à la main d' une infante d'espagne au
gabon je suis ici mais je vous jure mais
ce que j'aime chez jalousie que cela met
parfaitement légale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
invitez vos mots gentils amis un guichet
de votre vie en main à défaut de silence
la paix il faudra vous habituer à ce que
les voix sont passés du 1er mai jean
michel mouillot un poney que je suis le
neveu de messire camus donné mais bien
tendre de la prof et j'ai hâte d'arriver
à bordeaux pour va faire pour voir ma
fille mystérieux visiteur du soir et en
supposant que votre cheval sera aussi
bon que ma jument vous n'arriverez pas à
bordeaux avant 9 heures et alors et
alors tout le monde attendant que vous
êtes vous n'entrerez pas dans la ville
car toutes les portes sont fermées de la
porte cailhau à la porte de dijon
il faudrait pouvoir que l'on interdise
l'entrée d'une bonne ou non donc les
seigneurs mondiaux l'info serait plutôt
un bon boulot n'est pire m'est arrivé
une fois érigé j'ai brisé un rabattant
de la porte cailhau à coups de pierre et
vacances ou lors de la vente aux
vous êtes un vigoureux bon je dire oui
mais ça n'est rien après avoir brisé la
porte je suis trouvé face à un corps net
il ya dix ans noyau mis la main les pgm
et je tue trois hommes en reste de cette
je remet la main les jeux rock band
samedi et vous devez les trois autres à
dakar
au pq ou part dans la maison des jambes
voici venir notre bonhomme que samuel
pour servir ce brigand d'usuriers un
homme dit prête à 200%
ça s'appelle monsieur je n'ai presque
s'y engage et que vous ne m'avez jamais
rien je ne saurais tolérer qu'un par les
personnages ça c'est sous le même toit
que nous et moi ni moi ni moi monsieur
mon auberge est fait pour tout le monde
pas pour lui donc voilà ici j'ai refusé
la demande allait mais on vous jette
drap d'or
messieurs cet homme est infiniment
respectable et de plus il est mon ami tu
tes amis ne sont pas forcément vous êtes
car je suis tout seul
[Applaudissements]
mais aussi vrai je m'appelle raul de
blossac
je n'ai ni château ni terre et que
discussion tous m'ont bien je tue comme
un chien celui qui lie à mots plus imams
qu'est ce donc se nourrissant vous
voulez gérer votre famille monsieur mon
ami j'ai envie de vous mettre dans ma
poche et de vous mener à mes neveux
compris qu'ils adorent les journées si
on arrêtait les fanfaronnades
regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yann marec le désarmement et les postes
sont civilement que je pourrais passer
mon épée à travers rotterdam le corps je
préfère continuer ce combat une arme
messieurs s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
monsieur vous êtes un aimable garçons et
j'engage mes amis à faire comme moi
après tout nous ne sommes pas des
croquemitaines clodion de mardi ni les
georges haoui la jeunesse qui dit
mondial d'enfants galore le décastar eh
bien monsieur ma fiancée m'attend je
dois regagner bordeaux fut assez
dangereux parfois je ne sais pas fâché
de faire sauter n'accusez pas l'une de
ses portes de bordeaux mais c'est juste
pour voir
j'espère que sa mère
[Applaudissements]
monsieur je vous remercie
c é car monsieur samuel mon plat faire
mais croyez le bien
il ne devrait pas chasser un cylon
l'auberge tout pauvre simon je suis j'ai
plus la tour en simple vous le savez
mieux que sa première vie mary moins
cher simon faisait ces temps de guerre
allemand les bras c'est toi j'ai mes
risques team et l'a maintes fois prouvé
bon je vais prendre ma route de bordeaux
je peux matters est davantage mais vous
venez à peine d'arriver votre choix doit
être pourvus mais je sais mais il faut
compter 1 6 et 6 pas naïve vous prenez
fantaisie d'accéder cette nuit même à
bordeaux pourriez venir avec moi et il
pénétré à sans attendre l'ouverture des
portes au coup de canon du château
troupes
non mais c'est portes s'ouvriront devant
sans doute mais permettez moi de vous
inviter à souper avec plaisir j'aimerais
bien ça
[Musique]
oh
je suis un pauvre diable étaient
légendés paix malmené et qu'elle ait mis
peuple ainsi tous besoin mais à bordeaux
je suis un personnage sur notre capital
à nous autres israélite s'est autrefois
on voulait que nous embrassions les
catholicisme un peu plus tard on nous
permis de conserver la foi de nos pères
pourvu que nous livrions a aucune
pratique extérieure
maintenant on nous laisse libres
d'exercer notre région
pourvu que nous inquiétions nos impôts
et et vivian un bon citoyen mais cette
tolérance de l'homme ce que vous ouvrir
les portes de la ville pendant la nuit
oui et non simon simon darveau possible
merci me semble un ingé crois qu'hier la
nuit ne va pas tarder à tomber
si vous voulez coucher à bordeaux
n'avait qu'à me suivre mais laissé ici
votre cheval simon notre atelier vous
l'enverra dès maintenant un autre cela
ne me plaît pas beaucoup mieux que cela
tu dis moi tu iras
en ce moment on va vous allez à bordeaux
et ce pour y chercher fortune n'ont pas
redonné ma curiosité non votre question
des nuls loin du stress de mai à
bordeaux pour mieux marquer et de la
gagner l'amérique qu'ont à dire vient
d'éclater
vous venez de dire est dans l'auberge
n'avoir ni château ni terre et posséder
10 et qui pour tous bienvenue c'est la
pure vérité on ne va pas loin avec dix
équipes
les capitaines des navires ont pour
coutume de faire payer passage à c'est
qu'ils embarquent et je sais mais je
vous avouerai que je vais à bordeaux un
cousin fort bien classé sur lequel je
compte un peuple attend ça ça c'est tout
à fait différent des cendres et vous
surmonterez cousin non non non je
préfère les l'auberge mon cousin est
maintenant un grand seigneur et comme il
ya dix ans oui vous descendrez à
l'auberge avant dé lui rendant visible
on m'indique une rue des argentiers la
licorne devrait elle n'est pas loin des
motels et l'aubergiste éteindre les a
mis en route
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça nous arrivait bonsoir rade l'homme je
vous emmène les voyageurs c'est une des
mes meilleurs amis prenez bien soin de
lui je l'évoquerai points donnez-moi
gens dire bonsoir oncle sam bewley merci
mais je vous en mets l'entrée avait
bouffé au gentilhomme
oui mais je suis très las elle peut
vraiment dans ma chambre vimbouly pas le
sait pas dormir sans avoir coupé mais à
bordeaux les paupières de ce terme que
pour ceux qui ont l'estomac punta aller
asseyez-vous comme google wave
non je suis sûr belle julie n'est pas
parti en allemagne comme broken heart
précisément ce que ça fait de
positionner
qui sait pourtant persuadée qu'elle s'y
cachent plus et plus fun et sung
armoricain non car la mode à marty déjà
raconté que ce service en mai ses toiles
de toute façon je suis certain nombre de
choses la première c'est kamel justes de
camus
la seconde c'est que la maison du juif l
est ont pris part au centre-ville
cet homme là que dans la marquise
anglais en introduisant cette nuit
dansante sèmera la grande porte parce
qu'ils ont des attentes et c'est une
force avec laquelle je compte bien tout
à leur force et leur père a découvert en
faisant preuve que j'entends le voilà il
le fasse qu'il ne soit une chanson merci
ils vont nous séparer demain nous aurons
nous les jeunes
bonsoir mon seigneur et que la nuit soit
bonne pour le sera
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
felton
philippe de blossac mon cousin
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est une maison enchantée
m
l'image est tout
bien avait il dit
déjà à lever mot gentil sommes quand
même mettre également à brive et moi non
mais pardonnez ma surprise là je portais
souhaitez vous accueillir ce matin dans
une salle un peu plus accueillante aux
mots sur corner ceci n'est rien et
peut-être désirez vous visiter la ville
ou bien vous faire reconduire chez des
personnes à qui vous voulez ramon visite
vous savez je ne saurais trop mais force
est de rendre service à des amis de
l'oncle sam ou non rien de tout cela je
voulais seulement nous donner des films
de l'encré et du papier pour une
invasion margot et plus la papier radio
et je n'en ai ensuite de la faire porter
à mon cousin philippe de blossac vérité
monsieur est le cousin du comte son
cousin germain je crois c'est bien
situer dit que c'est laura de bordeaux
comme à votre seigneurie ne connaît pas
la faveur du compte que faveur un des
jurats de notre ville se nomme le
marquis de beauséjour et il a une très
jolie femme et madame de beauséjour est
le véritable reine de bordeaux 41 ans
est amoureux fou d'elle et mon cousin
alors j'y arrive est le cousin de votre
seigneurie et l'amant heureux lui de la
marquise de l'intendant et je le lui a
pas du tout tenez si votre cousin
désirent devenir gouverneur du château
trompette je suis sûr que lambda se fera
une joie d'aller demander au roi
faites-moi préparer des jeunes et pour
mon pays on a fait enlever du soleil et
et soif tout le temps voilà comme j'aime
la pratique mon cousin
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes un bien trop grands
personnages pour qu'un pauvre cadets
comme moi un personnage
aux vous allez voir sans vous annoncer
sa visite
voulez vous permettre de vous rencontrer
aujourd'hui votre cousin respectueux
ould abbès
[Applaudissements]
voici le plus dur je vous ai parlé
marbot attends-toi la porte et ceci au
château trompette
[Applaudissements]
à
j'y suis monsieur attendant la visite
vous surprend feeling mais je n'ai voulu
mettre personne dans la confidence aussi
parlerait sans détour des bruits qui
commence à circuler en ville
n'ignorez pas qu'il ya toujours des
oreilles attentives aux ragots dès
qu'ils peuvent nuire à l'autorité que je
représente
vous êtes le commandant second du
château trompette
ne l'oubliez pas philippe je suis trop
attaché à l'honneur pour l'oublier
monseigneur c'est ce que j'ai répondu un
porte des bruits courent disait ge que
toutes les nuits vous guider le château
trompette placé à ce moment là sous vos
ordres pour ne reprendre votre poste que
lorsque le jour va points
qu'avez vous à répondre à cela ce que
vous même avez répondu mon seigneur mon
cher philippe je suis obligé de vous
dire que je n'ai rien pu répondre vous
êtes ont donné des preuves
non aucune alors mon seigneur dois je
croire que vous écoutez les paroles de
gens poussaient par l'ambition la
méchanceté ou la jalousie
je ne puis croire monseigneur aussi ne
les a pas écoutés mais entendu ce qui
est fort désagréable et de surcroît fort
dangereux et moi mon seigneur je vous
prierais non seulement de m'écouter mais
de m'entendre aucune de mes paroles
aucune de mes actions ne peut porter une
atteinte si petite soit elle à votre
gouvernement
au contraire mon seigneur tout ce que je
puis faire n'a qu'un but celui de faire
cesser les intrigues qui vous inquiétez
vous importune je ne puis hélas vous en
dire plus pour l'instant mais je vous
prie de me croire et de me garder votre
confiance
bientôt
vous reconnaîtrez d'une manière
éclatante ma loyauté et bien
je vous fais confiance philippe
agissez comme bon vous semblera bon
capitaine il ya là une personne qui
demande à vous voir elle veut vous
remettre une lettre fait la rentrée
j'ai un message à vous transmettre de la
part de renault de blossac on s'énerve
il est à bordeaux
oui mon seigneur depuis hier soir
avantage tout les licornes
[Applaudissements]
y at il une réponse monseigneur une
réponse non
tu vas me conduire la licorne le guidant
à déjeuner en poison c'est impossible
comme après c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
alors non non non mais parce que mon
cuisinier est malade
venu vous pouvez pas vous faire crédit
avant j'avais des projets la plus belle
et la plus riche de bord à huy la plus
riche c'est maintenant aux mots drissi
pistoles et bien je tard andré mais
l'hôtelier wii dont m à ma table couvert
de ces messieurs qui sont mes amis
dans ce cas et bien mon cher décidément
les auberges nous sommes favorables
c'est toujours là qu'on rencontre ses
meilleurs amis
oui je vous demandais si vous avez passé
une bonne nuit et vous le pouvez mais
nous ne pouvons pas répondre
comment quelqu un treuil de jeunes
chevaux alors comprenez que tire bien et
vous même
je crois qu savoir où il apprend allez
tout savoir
[Applaudissements]
voilà fort villa regarde nous nous
occuperons du vôtre plus tard monsieur
non et si parler monsieur vous êtes
assis monsieur moi je suis debout c'est
juste pourriez peut-être vous lever
c'est ce que j'ai fait hier soir ans
yeux je sais vous m'avez suivi
vous auriez vous me suivre aujourd'hui
monsieur je ne dois pas rencontré le
diable ne rencontrerait pas le diable
mais mon épée c'est une arme loyal et je
la préférais fausses clés vous avez donc
s'il y en avait il vient de sortir de
votre bouche monsieur je t'assure fille
je vais vous donner un petit conseil il
est bon je suivrai
le v vous étirer votre épée
[Applaudissements]
iliad l'on éloigne les curieux venus et
retourne à tes fourneaux j'entends que
le légume sera bon le temps de tuer
monsieur et nous reprendrons nos
fourchettes
savez vous qui vous avez affaire non aux
chevaliers de torino la plus fine lame
de bordeaux monsieur veuillez choisir
vous-même l'endroit où vous allez tomber
voilà une gasconnades qui vous portera
malheur je n'ai pas l'honneur de vous
connaître monsieur mais je vais avoir la
douleur de vous tuer à moins que nous
puissions nous entendre
en vérité si vous voulez me donnez votre
parole de rentrer chez vous et leader
des lézards et pendant 48 heures
et pourquoi donc c'est mon secret mais
au gel de winne
vous êtes sans doute un ami du conte
philippe de blossac que je déteste parce
que son cousin
vous avez sûrement appris des choses
beaucoup de choses d'un officier du roi
cependant vous faites un bien vilain
métier un métier d'espion monsieur vous
m'insultez nous avons les armes à la
main et c'est mon droit soit en garde
monsieur vous l'avez voulu
[Musique]
et non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi
à
[Musique]
parfait moi j'ai eu la chance de l'être
que désarmé fallait à tout prix je fasse
taire un homme trop dangereux trop
dangereuse wauquiez je me dois la vérité
hier dès mon arrivée à bordeaux j'ai
appris un hasard miraculeux que mon
cousin philippe brassac et étant dans
une mare une conspiration de la marquise
de bosser josse un but précisément mais
vous le tenez où bordeaux est encore la
seule chose que j'ignorais c'est que
philippe doublet s'acquitter votre
cousin l'ignoriez aussi très
probablement la machination de marquise
et l'homme que je viens de tuer on était
dans les rouages ya de l'euro pour nous
débarrasser de ceux ci à lille
cet homme était un ennemi de l'oncle sam
uel de sognu ça je le savais je suis en
vérité je ne sais pas que le ministre se
dit écoutez moi le puck de passe dans
les caves
quel meilleur moyen de faire disparaître
une coche êtres aux nobles je me repasse
allemand oblige à un peu curieux aussi
et vous savez ce qu'on dit que l'eau du
pain gars le pouvoir de ressusciter les
morts
il va nous allons savoir tout de suite
avec cela
[Applaudissements]
oh
pareillement
[Musique]
quel bonheur de voir mon cousin
je ne t'avais vuc enfants mais ton
visage n'a pas changé et toi non plus tu
n'as pas changé
je reconnais tons chauds et après tant
d'années je désire tellement de
rencontrer la chose dit avant de faire
mon ami le comte de cohas les
compliments monsieur à propos de quoi
votre cousin s'est battu comme un lion
avec le chevalier de torigni qui a
blessé le chevalier je voulais tuer tuer
oui pour te protéger d'une mauvaise
histoire mais vraiment et on entretenait
un instant particulier vous permettez
content et je vous en prie
je suis très heureux de te revoir
j'avais besoin d'un ami fidèle et brave
c'est le ciel qui t'envoient tu arrives
au moment où j'étais seul et découragés
c'est surtout le commencement de cette
aventure qu'il faut que je te raconte
quand je suis arrivé à bordeaux
pauvre comme toi ambitieux et affamés
une lettre de recommandation mauvrit la
porte du château de compet
je devais invite cornette d'un régiment
un soir l'intendant dana un bal masqué
comme celui qui aura lieu ce soir il y
avait à ce bal une femme dont tous les
yeux des jeunes hommes m'ont dit le
regard commence la suite il je n'en sais
rien mais huit jours plus tard jeu
devint l'amante cette femme tu as deviné
c'était la marquise de beauséjour
[Musique]
n'y a pas qu'au bal masqué en portent
des masques
vous voyez mon vrai visage je n'en ai
pas d'autre
non
c'est celui du soldat du héros
tu héros
quand c'est qui si je le veux tu seras
si vous le voulez part que le pouvoir
le mien
c'est toujours obtenu ce que je désirais
toujours jusqu'à maintenant
j'espère le dire encore demain
tu n'as pas d'autres visant bien sûr
[Musique]
c'est pour cela que j'ai deviné si
facilement
j'aimerais mais ce virage il est
parfaitement ajustée à des gestes à
tenir sans doute je n'aime pas triché
encore moins lorsque je rencontre pour
la première fois ce dont je n'avais fait
que rêver si vous portez un masque
c'est un masque fascinant
[Musique]
c'est un masque de plaies
pourtant c'est tout ce que je dis signer
ce que je cache
non je ne cache rien et hier on ne peut
avoir peur
[Musique]
le sac
4e régiment de forteresse souhaiterais
tu m'aimais
ce qu'ils nous vendent ici
non reconnaissance de chacun d'eux
le souhaitent
si vous le permettez
[Musique]
je ne permets pas ou l'exigé presque
pourrais-tu campus exigé d'être aimé de
quelqu'un on peut le souhaiter tellement
profondément que l'on fini par l'obtenir
[Musique]
tu as réussi bravo merci
ne trahit jamais où je risque de
reprendre ma table
[Musique]
j'ignorais que les femmes pouvaient
jouer avec les coupes papier soit 130 je
ne la reprendrais pas
il faudrait pour cela que je me mette à
tes pieds rend là moi si tu n'as pas
peur
[Musique]
pendant cinq ans nous nous sommes adoré
et j'ai été le roi de bordeaux car les
plus puissantes même que l'intendant et
ce qu'elle veut le roi le veut peut-être
cet amour durerait t-il encore aussi
ardent qu'au premier jour
si je n'avais rencontré ça sarah est la
fille d'une soeur de samuel il y a trois
ans qu'elle est venue à bordeaux
et vite elle fit l'admiration de tous
par sa beauté et sa simplicité
un soir une demi douzaine de jeunes
hommes et chauffé par le jeu et la
boisson dans un tripot de la ville
firent un singulier pacte ils
s'engagèrent à me prêter main forte pour
enlever la belle juive et a tiré au sort
pour savoir qui serait son amant saml eu
vent de ce complot il 120 au château
trompette de réclamer la protection de
l'intendant ce fut moi qui le reçut le
rassurer lui promis l'aide demandée
le soir venu je m'en allais tout seul
chez samuel et vos sols dames dit-il
je n'en ai pas mais soyez sans crainte
mon épée est une solide campagne vers
minuit on frappe à la porte
la misérable troupes s'apprêtaient à
l'enlèvement j'ouvris moi même les deux
battants les assaillants étaient au
nombre de six jean tué deux sur le seuil
de la porte
profitant de la surprise puis jean
blessé deux autres le reste pris la
fuite
sarah descendit effrayés par le bruit de
la lutte
je ne l'avais jamais vu je fusible oui
o o
[Musique]
à
merci
ne me remerciez par demoiselle
cela me permet de vous voir je ne
connaissais que par votre oncle votre
présence dans cette demeure pour nous il
est difficile d'aller à vous ballet à
vous faites
certains soirs je préfèrerais rester
dans le calme d'une maison aussi
paisible elle déplaît quelques semaines
puisqu'ils ont essayé d'y pénétrer et
l'épée à la mer ce genre de compagnie
livrant il ne recule jamais devant la
violence c'est à vous qu'il s'en voulait
j'essaie tout ce qui est pur noble
discret des gènes ils essaient de
piétiner la beauté dans leur rage de ne
pouvoir se l'approprier
pourquoi demeurer vous dans cette ville
[Musique]
j'espérais trouver à bordeaux
on a pris plus sûres en allemagne il ne
me restait plus personne
[Musique]
pendant que samuel est le seul lien avec
ma famille je suis heureuse auprès de
lui maintenant que je vous ai rencontrés
j'aurai toujours des craintes pour vous
votre oncle ne peut plus suffire à vous
défendre lorsque vous sortez soyez
vigilante
[Musique]
mademoiselle depuis ce soir vous devenez
mon principal souci
alors je quitterai la vie de rien
permettez-moi seulement de passer
souvent pour veiller sur votre sécurité
[Musique]
je revins souvent fort souvent ciel
oncle sam uel un amour fou pour sarah
s'était emparée de moi je mesurais de
rompre avec la marquise et d'épouser sa
[Musique]
oh
tu viens moi depuis longtemps
cachés
dissimulés muet
comme si tu avais peur de te montrer
trop tôt
tu avais raison j'aurais peut-être été
sauvage maladroite
pendant tout ce temps je m'apercevais
que ton ombre inaccessible
si je souffrais c'était de ne pouvoir
toucher ta bouche
[Musique]
non
d'accord
a fini mon amour
monde est trop étrange
[Musique]
je regarde souvent à travers les volets
clos
couillet la rue
il me semble voir tourbillonner des
poissons
[Musique]
ils ne me voient pas ils ne l'entendent
pas
[Musique]
je machine nord fait elle peut être la
mienne
jusqu'à ce que toi tu viennes tu épouses
alors les vrais contours de mon vrai
monde alors j'oublie tout tout ce qui
n'est pas toi tout ce qui n'est pas
notre histoire
cette merveilleuse histoire silencieuse
secrète échapper au bruit et à la fureur
des villes et des rues sans chaude et
l'air
je ne mens jamais menti tu ne m'as
jamais et étrangers dès que j'ai vu j'ai
pensé il est enfin venu il s'est enfin
montré je ne savais pas qui tu étais ni
d'où tu venais tu n'avais pas besoin
d'avoir un nom que tu sois un cran pour
les uns un ennemi pour laisser aux
autres
pour moi tu est l unique
[Musique]
jutras cet affreux costume de soldat
je ne pourrais pas vivre si je devais
attendre pendant des mois et des mois la
plus belle victoire c'est ton visage
ressemble à celui des autres morts je
vais la guerre par au plus à obéir tout
cela je t'écoute respirer
ton coeur bat doucement
en égrenant m
je t'aime je t'aime
l'histoire avait fait beaucoup jaser
dans la ville sombre y parvint même
jusqu'aux oreilles de la marquise jc
cumul l'étau se resserre il nous faudra
quitter cette ville le plus rapidement
possible et vivre sans nous cacher nous
plus recourir à ces stratagèmes pour
passer quelques heures ensemble
mon pauvre à moi tu n'aurais jamais dû
au près dans la maison de sa mère
si pour toi c'était un piège mais tu es
l'air libre que je respire ma joie
mon unique joie je t'ai trouvé comme si
je t'avais cherché pendant des
millénaires ne souffre pas tant de mai
mais philippe accepte de cela tout
simplement avec un grand bonheur fait
confiance et de man ou partir en voyage
à temps sans impatience
je rêve tout le jour au moment où nous
seront délivrés c'est ainsi vieux rêve
pour nous je vais cette comédie que les
circonstances m'ont obligé à jouer
[Musique]
j'ai tellement peur d'être lâche toi un
lâche
mais n'est ce pas toi qui m'a délivré de
ces ivrognes furieux c'est très simple
de se battre l'épée à la main mais
beaucoup plus difficile d'affronter
certaines forces qui te paralysé de
clouer au sol avec d'autres armes et
d'autres lois
malgré tout mon courage je me sens
ligoté vaincu
[Musique]
c'est ton amour
qui me permettrait de faire front
et de nous délivrer
[Musique]
et un matin l'intendant mort de notes
d'aller conduire un convoi de munitions
loin très loin de bordeaux
c'était une manoeuvre de cette tigresse
la marquise de beauséjour qui rend même
temps faisait ordonnée par l'intendant
le renvoi de sarah en allemagne
aujourd'hui elle soupçonne fort sarah de
se cacher encore dans la maison de son
angle et nous rencontres sont pour elle
tellement probable qu'elle charge ces
espions de vérifier voilà mon cher raul
tu connais toute l'histoire tu es plus
que mon cousin maintenant tu mon frère
et c'est désormais entre nous à la vie à
la mort
je t'adresse philippe et possédé de la
marquise sont formés prise à bhl et les
blausasc ne peuvent-ils rester
indifférent merci il y à ce soir le bal
masqué à noël au château trompette
je te ferai parvenir une invitation
ainsi qu est ton ami le comte de koras
[Musique]
on
on sait dans la vie son petit colombie
comment vous n'appréciez pas c'est votre
femme shera vie
le corps est volontiers sa tournure et
presque la mairie exactement la même et
là j'ai la preuve du contraire j'ai la
douleur de vous apprendre que la
marquise à priver vos salons de cervélo
impossible voyant je vous répète que ma
femme n'est pas tout je sais bien angles
et beaucoup ne serait terminée
parce qu'elle est retenue au lit
souffrant d'une horrible migraine et
bien pourtant je vous parie sans louis
mon cher ami que la séduisante que l'on
devinait la marquise d'ô ses jours ne
sont une seule et même comme ça
c'est top
[Musique]
et
en soir quand
reconnaissez
suivez-moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
non